joining me now is matt walsh host of the
matt wall show matt it's almost like
they're throwing it in our face is that
how you feel
yes especially when you see how they're
all dressed and they look i mean when i
went to school
teachers they all look like librarians
now they look like drug addicts and
carnies and it's just but it's part and
parcel part and parcel what the overall
issue which is the total moral anarchy
in the public school system and also the
fact that it's overrun by these leftist
radicals because guess what you know
when you look at the stuff happening on
college campuses and all the crazy
marxist students and everything and we
like to console ourselves and say well
they'll get into the real world and
they'll change no they get into the real
world and they become teachers so the
system just feeds itself and this is
what we end up with and they're so
stupid they're putting it out all over
social media it's like those criminals
that commit crimes and then they take
pictures of themselves with the stolen
merchandise and put it on instagram do
you worry though that the country is so
focused
on ukraine that the left is doing stuff
behind our back i just saw the other day
that they just announced biden shattered
more
illegal immigration records like he
doesn't deport anybody like no one's
been deported ice hasn't made any
arrests
um i worry about that do you worry about
that
yeah i certainly do worry about it i
mean of course things that are happening
across the world are always going to be
important and uh and all of that but
this is this is stuff that's happening
right now i mean look in the school
system we've got 50 million kids that go
every day into these indoctrination
camps and that's just public schools
private schools aren't much better i got
news for you so um yeah you might be
worried about what's happening overseas
in other countries but this is happening
in our country right now our kids are
being subjected to this every single day
you know and for them it's they got to
imagine sitting in a classroom with
somebody like that every single day you
know seven hours a day five five days a
week for you know so many years
carnies that's a good way to describe it
matt walsh thanks so much for joining us
thank you